if summer doesn't sing in you then
nothing sings In
You And if nothing sings in you that you
can't make
music something she told
me hello I'm Lenny hello
Felicia oh she's so beautiful tell me
about oh she's wonderful she's a lovely
girl what age are we living in one can
be as free as one un likes without guilt
or confession please I know exactly who
you
are he can be the first Great American
conductor there's a price for being in
my brother's orbit you know
that
[Music]
I love people so much that it it's hard
for me to be
alone that music it keeps me glued to
life
I don't even know how much you need me
to I
[Music]
might if s doesn't sing in you then
nothing sings In
[Applause]
You And if nothing sings in
you and you can't make me
[Music]
music